eu vi ele vai começar em três da spam
bots pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar que
sejam muito burro vindo jamais um vídeo
e hoje trago cheque url to
é bom este ano foi recomendado por vocês
que supostamente estão jogando um
palhaço que anda atrás nós de mim porque
eu fui capaz de armazenar e office boy
vou te dizer durante a noite do teu
aniversário para este ataque um acertou
vocês indo atrás de mim para olha não
está já eu estou convicto convencido e
tenho certeza que tudo vai julgar é
jogar o que cai o um livro do que assume
carácter não deixa a galera supostamente
não podemos olhar o palhaço é egípcio
quiser sofria ó claro que eu quero
morrer é a primeira coisa que vai poder
fazer neste jogo não é encontra as
quatro velas para salvar e lançou suba
para comportar um pano e então um kit 21
é o [ __ ] encontrar sabe que vai fazer
um livro aberto ou seja tem que
encontrar a chave para sair fadas
exatamente aqui o design esse mesmo
tempo por saber que a porta foi cortado
e eu estou livre vai começar quando é
que eu estou será posto 14 em dublin o
evento é e tua mãe zinha gostosa que eu
já comi ontem à noite é você vai cair
todos num quarto aparentemente eu já
tenho uma vem é quem andou o começo é
inteligente e clean e isso está muito
alto
olha aqui 10 foi o que eu fiz foi eu sou
muito artista é suportável
foi muito rápido joga baralho é muito
grande esta casta ouvi um barulho
estranho lá em baixo carbono
eu acho que o chinelo acho que ela é uma
janela estava não é uma janela pois foi
acionado aqui embaixo
fui depois a sondar no tt botafogo
vamos continuar a trabalhar em belém já
que a gente não precisa de uma estrutura
do meu coração é que nisto não sei que o
turismo não vamos lá não vamos fugir
daqui cara está muito alto muito alto
alguns até na televisão cara verão verão
disse por sua hora o qual é preciso
outra desde que o primeiro não podia
vela fofucho fui sul mil junto à lei foi
apenas aquela novela muito rápido muito
rápido e velo 29 20 anos não sei
ai meu deus gente está com muito sucesso
para nero está por ser muito vai torcer
muito já a mesma que não olha pra onde
eu não olha aqui não não é um ótimo deu
vai-vai posto foi o cool na frente não
pode ser ou não está a deixar fugir eu
não te deixar fugir e não ter gostado
deste objectivo é conseguir sempre um
nêutron áreas do jazz fez a playboy está
batendo à porta com muita força e é
muito forte tem duas portas daquela
porta já não funciona [ __ ] se aquela
porta e agora pode acontecer
foi só meu isto andar às voltas eu já
não sei de quanto já eu acho que é por
ali né por luisa pai muito devagar muito
de um quarto sem nada como eu estava à
espera disto
ae burnley stoke 23 733 futebol pode
ganhar um anel é isso é isso entramos na
casa de banho estão um lugar perigoso
casa de banho é muito perigoso revela
outra bela ele
no estudo que eu precisava foi alguma
coisa está surrado que vem do botafogo
lam piollin do estado lugar estou assim
imagina dentro do meu coração
a oi fm merda fiz merda fiz merda fiz
merda agora o que eu faço
aí eu não vi tocando piano agora sabe
que eu tô aqui eu sabe que eu estou aqui
eu não tava por serem mais lugar nenhum
o que é bom né
o professor o eu entrei aqui isso não
estava aberto o botafoto olhar sobre um
cofre
gosto muito de me encontrar o código ae
quando abriu se uma porta [ __ ] fosse
lançada por e-mail e isso é obra de luís
é o brasileiro que eu tenho que fazer
agora é só vai pra um alô bolicenho
histórias por aí meu espanto ou o
conseguiu não consigo andar e carregado
amo muito e me derrubou por marco
lorenzo o gregory martini ter certeza
meu nome fuster rodas são jardins bom
pessoal vamos ficar por aqui com este
vídeo espero que vocês tenham gostado e
mantém gostei do jogo os preços dos
homens já sabem o quanto eu vou sair
favorito fimma e aproximar